when I got to the [__] airport
finally this chick this girl
who had to be 22.
you know people come up to me sometimes
whatever I'm I'm ready for it and [__] I
see him come I see you coming by the way
from like you're not being sneaky you
know
people think they're like Cato
and I uh and the guy and this girl goes
like this uh
and I go hey and she says
beer pong
and I go
well what the [__] is going to be
happening at this point from now on what
kind of reaction am I gonna have to
[__] drum up
she goes beer pong and I and I say
huh
and she says I met you last night during
beer pong
and I say
nah not me and she says yeah it was you
and everybody's listening and I'm sure
some of those people are like this idiot
got it wrong she does doesn't realize
that that's the comedian and she maybe
recognizes him that way
and is confusing someone else's [__]
janky face playing beer pong maybe she
was drunk and now she thinks Crystal
Chris Dalia was playing beer pong with
her by the way
there are some people that think that
but the people who don't know who I am
are looking at me like oh this [__]
guy doesn't want to seem like he was
playing beer pong with a 22 year old
so now I look like a [__] creep
she goes beer pong 22 year old and I say
huh 39 year old and she says Metro last
night playing beer pong and I say
wouldn't me and she says yeah it was
dude
quit blowing my fake cover it wasn't me
first of all
I would never play beer pong dude if I
drank I first of all I've never drank
period ever end of story full stop do I
like when people say that no
but full stop
uh I've never drank okay
so I know I didn't play beer pong even
if I did if I drank every day like a
[__] fish
I would never play beer pong I you know
why because I don't need a reason to
drink if I'm gonna drink I'm just gonna
[__] put the [__] to my mouth and
then ingest it in my body you're not
gonna try and get a I gotta get I gotta
make it harder give me all the alcohol
put it inside me and let me be drunk as
[__] beer pong you know I wouldn't even
play ping pong how about that you're
gonna give me a paddle now this [__]
ass little thing no way